[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je dis 19 avril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 e tour
d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition son avenir n'est pas encore
tracé depuis plus d'un an la ferme de
bulles loyer à magny les hameaux et
inoccupé faute de financement aucun
projet concret n'a été définie pour ce
lieu propriété de saint quentin en
yvelines afin d'alerter sur ce sujet un
pique nique a été organisée sur place
par une association du territoire elle
est l'une des premières cités ouvrières
de trappes les dombes s'ils ont une
place importante dans l'histoire de la
ville construit dans
l'entre-deux-guerres pour accueillir les
cheminots l'ensemble a bien failli être
détruit avant d'être classée en 1992 un
livre lui est consacrée nous recevons
son auteur à nice à l'abri et puis
retour au moyen-age à la fin de ce
journal l'association à la compagnie
excalibur yvelines pratique les combats
médiévaux
elle nous a accueillis à chevreuse pour
tester la discipline invité de ce
journal également deux étudiantes de
levier est ce qu représentante de
l'association elsa versailles à la pour
but l épanouissement à des étudiants en
droit au niveau européen c'est à suivre
dans ce journal
après deux jours de grève à la sncf le
retour à la normale doit avoir lieu
demain vendredi le mouvement perdez des
cheminots elle doit prendre fin à 8
heures mais quelques perturbations
devraient subsister à dans la journée de
demain à saint quentin en yvelines pour
les utilisateurs d du réseau transilien
sur le rer c c et trois trains sur
quatre et qui sont prévues du côté de la
ligne n trafic quasi-normal 9 trains sur
10 prévue pour demain
enfin sur la ligne lui c'est un trafic
normal pour demain vendredi afin de
connaître tous les derniers horaires
d'information est consultée dans tous
vos horaires de train un rendez vous sur
le site transilien.com associations et
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
s'inquiètent du devenir de la ferme de
bus loué
et à magny les hameaux je vous le disais
dans les titres depuis plus d'un an elle
est inoccupée suite au départ des
jardins de cocagne un avenir incertain
le collectif ce qui pousse à organiser
un pique nique pour échanger et
sensibiliser sur ce sujet à camille
lambert marion ptac et patrick jacques
de dixmude sur ses quatre hectares de
terres poussait une soixantaine de
variétés de légumes de saison en
agriculture biologique
créée en 2010 les jardins de cocagne ont
été obligés de quitter les lieux pour
raisons financières en 2016
depuis la ferme de bulles loyer est
inoccupée samedi 14 avril le collectif
ce qui pousse qui réunit associations et
habitants s'est retrouvé pour un pique
nique d'information et des changes ce
qui nous préoccupait fortement c'était
en craignait fortement que sept fermes
disparaissent dans les mains d'un
promoteur ils soient démantelées en
petits lots comme ça arrive souvent
donc ça c'est des rumeurs qui
commençaient à monter du coup on voulait
en savoir plus ce qu'on souhaite c'est
qu'à travers le pique nique ont souhaité
interpeller déjà les habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines et en même temps nos
élus sur le devenir de cette belle ferme
de ubu loyers en octobre 2017
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines propriétaire de la ferme a
signé une convention avec la safer pour
trouver un nouveau projet sur ce lieu le
collectif regrette le manque de
communication et souhaite conserver le
côté local comme c'était le cas avec les
jardins de cocagne
on n'a aucune information sur ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui est c'est quoi le
contenu de cette convention et c'est
quoi les projets pour ce pour cette
ferme et on s'inquiète beaucoup en fait
on veut pas que c'était en perdre sa
vocation agricole tout simplement parce
qu on y est attaché l'intérêt de
rapprocher l'agriculture
des citoyens surtout en ile de france on
est quand même assez éloignée des
tanneries culture je pense que c'est un
terrain propice à des expérimentations
enfin si saint-quentin veut vraiment
être dans le mouvement on va dire dans
le mouvement actuel on voit bien que
s'il ya un engouement réel
contacté par nos soins l'agglomération a
indiqué que l'appel à projets a été
lancé et suit son cours même si l'avenir
de la ferme reste incertain il devrait
rester agricole est la visite de marlène
schiappa hier mercredi à plaisir la
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes s'est
rendu à la maison des familles
flora tristan a sur place elle a pu
rencontrer les membres 2000 et un mot
cette association aide les parents dans
l'éveil du langage de leurs enfants
avant l'entrée en maternelle une action
pour donner les mêmes chances à chaque
enfant à l'école marlène schiappa est
d'ailleurs devenue la marraine de cette
structure propos recueillis par marion
ptac et patrick jacques de dixmude dans
une ludothèque dans une unité de lieu et
bien il ya des parents qui partage
autour des jeux qui font découvrir à
leurs bébés la découverte de l'objet du
livre
et puis la découverte des mots et les
changes de quelques pratiques entre les
parents pour avoir véritablement une
interaction et une communication
efficace avec leurs enfants pour qui à
terme cette acquisition du langage elle
soit plus facile pour les enfants et
aussi pour les bas rhin
pour nous c'est important parce que
aujourd'hui notre association elle
travaille sur un certain nombre de
terrains plutôt en ile de france dans
les yvelines à paris dans le val de
marne
mais on veut montrer aussi que elle a
une ambition nationale puisque le modèle
qu'on a développée donc des groupes de
parents avec une maman ambassadrice ce
modèle il peut être étendue à beaucoup
d'autres territoires et on est persuadé
que un peu partout en france
il ya des mamans ambassadrice potentiel
qu'on pourrait trouver une invitée à
présent avec moi sur ce plateau à nice à
la mairie bonsoir vous êtes la
responsable des mémoires de tram c'est
un service municipal alors vous publié
aux éditions bouquet lis ce livre la
cité des dents de scie histoire d'un
patrimoine
un ouvrage consacré à cette cité chemine
de cheminots atypique menacé de
destruction puis classés on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans cet
entretien des gens
en quelques mois la ville de trappes a
vu des ouvrages sortis ruiz sur la ville
de trappes il ya eu une enquête menée
par deux journalistes du monde alors la
démarche n'est pas là la même que la
vôtre mais pourquoi votre avis trappe
c'est un bon sujet pour écrire un livre
alors certainement parce que c'est une
ville très ancienne moi je travaille sur
l'histoire de la ville donc je peux en
certifié et il ya beaucoup de choses à
écrire et à raconter sur cette ville qui
a qui a quand même changé qui évoluent
au cours des années au cours des siècles
et qui a beaucoup de choses à raconter
alors cette cité des dents si vous y
avez habité vos grands parents sont
arrivés sur place en 1939
c'est cette histoire aussi qui vous a
motivé à écrire ce livre peut-être des
souvenirs d'enfance que vous avez aussi
un hommage à la mémoire de vos grands
parents oui tout à fait en fait on a
toujours une affection pour toucher une
affection et sa maison d'enfance et en
fait c'est lors d'un déjà d'un travail
universitaire que j'avais fait donc des
recherches sur cette cette cité donc au
niveau architectural et historique et
c'est surtout les témoignages que
j'avais recueilli qui m'ont conforté
dans l'idée de publier ce livre là
qu'est ce qu'elle veut 17 sites et des
deux bandes si sur l'histoire de trappes
l arrêt des témoignages à large et j'ai
pu grâce à tous les témoignages que j'ai
recueillis remonter jusqu à son origine
toutes les années 30 et pu retracer un
peu toute l'histoire de la ville dont
quatre ont une partie où ça parle des
bombardements donc la reconstruction
tout ce que les habitants ont supporté
et puis surtout la menace de démolition
qui a quand même été un choc
c'est psychologique est important pour
les habitants pour les locataires qui
avait fait beaucoup de travaux et qui y
voyaient un petit peu l'heureux vers
leur patrimoine partir un petit peu
enfumée
alors si on revient sur l'histoire cette
cité des anciens été construite à la fin
des années 1920 et ça répondait à
l'époque à une problématique de l'eau
hier 131 9 sans profession est en fait
c'était pour abriter les cheminots qui
commençait à
être arrivés massivement à cause du
triage qui prenait beaucoup d'ampleur
donc qui est installée en 1911 et qui
commençait vraiment à prendre beaucoup
d'ampleur
donc il a fallu les abriter et pour ça
des des cité cheminote pardon ont été
construits pour eux elle accueille oui
donc pendant de nombreuses années ces
familles de cheminots trappe mais encore
rien à voir avec la ville aujourd'hui
l'huile de rentrer il habite en fait une
ville davy est environ 3000 habitants
l'époque donc petite ville c'est des
habitations qu'on appelle à l'époque ddh
bmd des habitations bon marché qui sont
les ancêtres dhr oui tout à fait oui
conçu pour deux séries est conçu aussi
pour abriter assez rapidement donc les
des constructions sérielle à l'image de
déconstruction allemande et des
cités-jardins aussi anglaise un saut
dans le temps vous en reparler dans les
années 1980 la cité est menacé de
destruction par son bailleur de l'époque
un lot pierrois qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui les résidents yvelines
essonne oui ces bailleurs prévoit de
larrazet à l'époque 7
elle n'est pas entretenu cette cité
n'est pas entretenue donc c'est vraiment
les locataires qui qu'il faut les
travaux nécessaires nous quand nous
sommes partis ne l'a vu encore
l'électricité qui étaient aux normes des
années 30 par exemple d'accord en 1992
et donc justement grâce à la
détermination de locataires la la cité
va être sauvé et chose unique en france
elle sera inscrite à l'inventaire
supplémentaire des monuments historiques
tout à fait elle aurait dû être classé
mais comme un de ces architectes étaient
encore vivants le
ça n'a pas pu être reclassés elle a été
en tout cas sauvegardés par la
municipalité aussi qui beaucoup aussi
renommées pour pouvoir la protéger quand
vous parlez de locataires est-ce que
depuis que vous avez quitté aspects des
26 qu'elle a beaucoup changé
cette cité non halal a été en tout cas
réhabiliter déjà donc il a fallu trouver
l'argent les fonds dont c'est aussi ce
que je raconte ça a été cinq ans de
recherche de financement est depuis non
chaque travaux en fait doit être fait
dans les règles de l'art et en
concertation avec l'adf donc
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
on y trouve encore des familles de
cheminots oui encore quelques unes qui
sont revenus et qui résiste encore une
dernière question est ce que ce livre a
été difficile à écrire est ce que par
exemple oui recueillir des informations
sur le sujet a été difficile pour vous
c'était pas évident de retrouver les
gens qui habitaient puisque beaucoup
sont repartis dans leur région dans leur
pays notamment les normands les bretons
les vendéens tous ceux qui sont arrivés
à l'époque pour travailler sur le triage
donc c'était compliqué de retrouver les
témoignages
alors encore un long avenir devant elle
celle ci fait des 26 j'espère j'espère
j'espère que ce livre et contribuera en
tout cas merci à la lys à l'abri d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous
publié aux éditions bouquet lis donc ce
livre la cité des dents de scie histoire
d'un patrimoine un ouvrage consacré donc
à cette cité cheminots atypique
alors pour retrouver et celui pour vous
le procurez vous pouvez notamment vous
rendre sur le site de bouquets liste qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
on vous en parlait largement hier dans
le 7-8 journal le soleil et le beau
temps se sont installés sur toute la
france une bonne nouvelle pour les
yvelinois en cette période de vacances
scolaires et c'est aussi le cas pour le
secteur du tourisme avec le début du
printemps le ciel bleu permet aux sites
de faire le plein c'est le cas notamment
dans les campings exemple à rambouillet
avec à nicolas kirillovitch c'est un
signe annonciateur de bonnes nouvelles
le chant des oiseaux est de retour dans
la forêt de rambouillet dans ce camping
la saison a débuté il ya trois semaines
déjà mais l'arrivée d'une météo estivale
marque le véritable retour des clients
on est rempli à 90% sur nos locatifs
pour ce week-end
donc c'est plutôt un très bon week-end
et ensuite évidemment il ya la partie
la partie camping qui va se remplir mais
avec moins de réservations ça puisse
être du passage qui va vraiment pour le
coup dépendre du soleil qui va être avec
nous ce week end c'est toujours beaucoup
plus agréable et il est sûr que c'est un
impact important et dynamisant sur sur
les réservations au milieu des arbres et
en pleine nature l'offre de logements
est aussi variés qu original pour un
camping avec des cabanes et cahute
notamment 200 emplacements au total mais
une piscine encore en cours de
préparation pour les beaux jours
la piscine naturelle et non chauffés
donc nous demande d'attendre un petit
peu que l'eau chauffe aussi est ce qui
nous laisse un peu de temps pour
nettoyer pendant la saison le soleil est
quand même primordial il est toujours
plus compliqué d'aller se baigner sous
la pluie c'est une piscine non couvertes
les yvelinois seront sûrement nombreux à
vouloir profiter du week-end printanier
qui s'annonce si le camping de
rambouillet est déjà presque plein une
quinzaine d'autres sites dans les
yvelines offre une escapade entre la
nature et les chants des oiseaux
j'accueille de nouvel invité sur ce
plateau deux étudiantes en droit à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines à ma droite mcdyess là où sonne
bonsoir vous êtes étudiante en master 1
droit public et in dakar pout soglo
bonsoir vous êtes vous est étudiante en
licence de droit et sciences politiques
alors vous êtes venu nous parler de
votre association elle à versailles
lancé tout récemment à lui vs cul et
linda vous êtes vous en être la
présidente mcgale vous en être là la
vice présidente marketing donc de cette
association elsa versailles alors elle a
ordonné mois déjà pour mon qu'être
accent anglais ça veut dire european
love to dance et son association
on va s'arrêter là voilà c'est une
association au niveau européen qui
regroupe des étudiants en droit les
présentes dans 44 pays
quelles sont les missions de cette
association en effet elsa en fait c'est
une association qui se
dirige vers les étudiants en droit c'est
vraiment l'idée de créer un entourage
professionnel auprès des étudiants en
droit des professionnels et des deux des
professeurs elles existent actuellement
dans 44 pays
c'est à dire nous avons actuellement 376
faculté qui sont présentes et c'est un
réseau à peu près environ de 50 mille
étudiants en droit dans toute l'europe
et aussi au delà de leurs hôtes mais
voilà à votre avis mondial pourquoi ce
dialogue entre les étudiants européens
endroit est important pourquoi il faut
faciliter ces échanges
tout simplement parce que ça nous permet
de connaître un peu le rayonnement en
fait tout ça enfin comment dire à
l'exemple la présidente a eu l'occasion
d'assister à une conférence sur l'oms et
shiloh voilà une heure du lot et donc du
coup ça lui a permis de rencontrer les
étudiants en droit de se créer un réseau
sa part de richesse sociale et sa
richesse à une richesse à la fac
culturel mais aussi par rapport à notre
cursus d'avoir des cours des
interventions en anglais ça permet
d'améliorer l'anglais l'idée de l'europe
au delà de toute considération politique
est ce que c'est une idée qui vous tient
à coeur cette idée de l'europe
elsa est par principe une organisation
politiquement et religieusement neutre
mais en effet l'idée de l'europe de
l'est change en fait pas de leur sens
politique institutionnelle est vraiment
notre idée principale notre mission de
permettre cet échange international ai
dans plusieurs échelles alors vous
voulez il ya 300 groupes locaux d'elza
donc répartis sur tout le territoire
européen un groupe local de désormais tu
as lu vs cul et les adversaires pourquoi
lancer justement ce groupe elsa à
versailles à l'université versailles
saint quentin
je vais je vais me permettre de répondre
et bien sûr un mac do peut me joindre
mais elsa c'est vraiment une expérience
unique
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire partie de
le du groupe local de l'université de la
sorbonne de paris 1 et 7 pour moi cette
est une nécessité en fait de permettre
de l'accès aux étudiants cet outil en
fait qui va permettre de à la fois
d'avoir un réseau professionnel
académique et de cet échange avec
l'international au niveau local aussi
puisque nous avons actuellement à paris
huit organisations dont répartis dans
les facultés de droit
donc il s'agit vraiment d'une
coopération sous l'affluence du
multiculturalisme et ça permet
exactement comme au mondial a souligné
d'avoir des plus plusieurs opportunités
par exemple avec des stages actuellement
nous avons un programme lancé avec plus
que 300 candidatures au stage donc tout
le monde est bien sûr les conférences
les séminaires les délégations auprès
des plus grandes institutions
internationales à l'occupant occurrence
moi j'ai pu avoir l'opportunité de faire
une délégation auprès de l'unesco
donc ça me permet vraiment étudiants
d'avoir un accès à la vie
professionnelle
donc si je comprends bien ce que vous me
dites vous proposer plusieurs choses il
ya des stages dans des cabinets à
l'étranger c'est ça et d'autres
événements peut-être des visites
institutionnelles aussi avec notre
association les nappes et sa ligne chez
stationary visite et donc du coup c'est
l'occasion d'aller dans un autre pays 2
d'apprendre culturellement et aussi de
visiter notamment strasbourg et dans la
ville européenne donc il ya énormément
de viser qui se fait elle strasbourg est
l'occasion de visiter aussi le conseil
le conseil de l'europe et la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme donc
voilà donc plein de plein d'opportunités
exclu depuis le lancement à albi vs qu
est ce que le groupe a évolué vous avez
déjà des demandes qui vous ont ou qui
vous ont rejoint oui actuellement du
coup on nous ne pouvons être que dès
aujourd'hui au plateau mais nous sommes
une équipe de 20 personnes
donc déjà c'est vraiment un début très
très ambitieux pour nous et oui voilà
très prometteur est également nous avons
plusieurs membres qui commence à
apprendre l'association apprendre les
enjeux les stages voilà c'est il ya
plusieurs activités en fait c'est
exactement ça permet aux étudiants
d'avoir une réseau professionnel auprès
des institutions organes des
organisations internationales mais aussi
auprès des professionnels des cabinets
d'avocats et c'est un dernier mot
ignorer ce pont de 30 secondes on peut
vous souhaiter tout le bonheur du monde
que beaucoup d'étudiants à demain notre
association et surtout qu'ils viennent
faire partie de l'équipe
elsa est ce que ça apporte énormément je
m'amuse
depuis que j'ai mon poste de vp
marketing et c'est super cool c'est une
super asos donc venez nombreux et vous
pourrez retrouver en tout cas toutes les
informations sur l'association elle à
versailles sur le groupe et les à
versailles sur la page facebook de ce
groupe qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous deux chiens fait que
j'avais avec moi autour de la table
mcddi lawson et elin dakar coude soglo
merci d'avoir été avec nous elle le
sport il a fait le tour des médias en
courant le dernier marathon de paris
pieds nus sidy diallo a terminé la
course en un peu moins de quatre heures
sans chaussures une philosophie de vie
pour cet hymne imite un de 63 ans qui
n'en était pas à son coup d'essai en
huit ans il a participé à 160 marathon
dont 21 pieds nus il s'est confié au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude et
michael et demi d'euros la première fois
que je suis sortie du chemin à pied nu
c'était en juin 2015
de montigny et donc ça fait moins de
trois ans le début était très difficile
mais maintenant au moins sur l'asphalté
quand je suis l'asphalt je n'ai aucun
problème pour les pieds nus et des
halles à paris je réalise aimons l'un
d'eux est mal tombée plus rapide en 3h54
et vient chez n'est donc
sept jours plus tard à bonn 7 dimanche
dernier avec et 9 me à la fin de pieds
nus et là j'ai réalisé mon meilleur
temps pieds nus sur la distance du
marathon
23h47 entretien complet avec sidy diallo
a retrouvé dans le 7-8 sports lundi
prochain à 18h30 sur tv 78 activité pour
le moins sportive encore mais quelques
siècles en arrière une association
yvelinoise de passionnés s'adonnent aux
combats médiévaux tenue équipements et
techniques d'époque sont utilisés est
michael et demi d'euros est allé à leur
rencontre château de la madeleine à
chevreuse il s'est reconverti chevalier
et enfiler cotte de maille épée et
bouclier pour tester ces disciplines et
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous propose aujourd'hui de remonter
le temps et de vous arrêter à l'époque
du moyen-age une association baptisée
escalibur yvelines s'est créé il ya cinq
ans à mes côtés son président arnaud de
maizière arnaud concrètement qu'est ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui
avant on va s'équiper on va se perdre en
armure et on va combattre comme au
troisième siècle c'est pas trop lourd
une armure non les gens y arriver on y
va on va y arriver
oui c'est parti
alors là on est devant la fameuse armure
allait proposer de quelle matière
expliquez-nous
alors là en fait vous avez l'armure d'un
homme d'armes une 13e siècle dont
quelqu'un de comme assez aisée c'est pas
forcément un chevalier ça plutôt être un
piéton donc on va voir une première
couche de textile faire bien absorber
les coûts et par dessus on va mettre une
couche de métal de méthode alors là on à
de la maille alors je vais regarder déjà
je vais un peu soupeser ah oui
effectivement
oui c'est entre 10 et 15 kg 12 et 15 kg
avait le poids total c'est autour de 25
kg c'est bon je suis entré dépôts et à
certains endroits on va avoir des
parties métalliques solide mais c'est
surtout une armure textile parce que
l'essentiel de la défense ok donc
bouclier cote de maille tout
l'équipement 25 kg c'est ça à peu près
on va l'enfiler c'est parti que des
pâquis pour rien non vous tester
on va tester auquel tu as des armes dont
vous pliez ton ep sur ton ep
mieux il vient d'en sortir c'est bon tu
as toutes ses chances
ok
t'as pas beaucoup d'armure faut protéger
que le bouclier donc tu vas essayer de
toujours le tendre à peu près comme ça
ton ep t'as pas de protection aux mains
il faut que tu as frappé
tu te mets en garde lorsque tu feras qui
tend le bras assez appuyé vers nos
droits voilà là tu attaques voiture bien
et tu essayes de parts avec le bouclier
des bruits tous et bonne chance
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
donc
si j'ai bien compris comme ça
ah oui d'accord pour envoyer les
gentiment
résiste résister à pluie
les gens disent les gens
romancière
[Musique]
très bien ça va suffire je pense que tu
es prêt à rejoindre l'association
je suis prêt tu es prêt je me retirais
la côte de mal parce que j'ai vraiment
trop trop chaud tous les ans pas la
cotisation
effectivement
merci beaucoup pour ce cours
d'initiation alors comment on fait pour
s'inscrire à l'association à tous les
détails sont sur le site
excalibur et bling point fr ne vous
faites pas que la reconstitution on fait
aussi des imac chefs ont des protections
adaptées
et encore plus dangereux encore plus
dangereux c'est moins lourd peut-être au
niveau d'armure plus chaud du show bon
bah on va continuer à tester un petit
peu ce sport plaisir
[Musique]
allez après le moyen-age on part
direction l'asie a pour terminer ce
journal pendant les vacances la ville de
plaisir propose des ateliers culinaires
culturelles et artistiques sur la
thématique escale en asie
hier après-midi camille lambert a
assisté à une découverte de la peinture
à l'encré de chine regarder pas un mot
pas un bruit
la concentration est à son maximum le
travail à la plume et à l'encré de chine
demande une précision à toute épreuve et
une imagination débordante
comme quand on a l'habitude de regarder
les nuages et qu'on imagine des formes
qu'on voit à l'intérieur
le but c'est que les enfants dans les
fonds et les formes d'encre qu'ils ont
fait un nom en arrière qui puisse
imaginer bas un univers un paysage des
personnages et utilisez la couleur pour
réhausser ses formes là et donner vie en
fait alors à leur dessein insectes aux
paysages des univers délicat et poétique
une véritable découverte pour les plus
jeunes hafsa ibrahim utilisent cet outil
pour la première fois j'ai mis des
décors idée là j'ai fait un ours avec
des couleurs massé joule
et là j'ai fait des points el guerrouj
des couleurs les belles couleurs elle
était belle et des et j'aime bien les
silos a pu après une escale en asie
proposé par la ville de plaisir pendant
les vacances
les prochains ateliers vous emmèneront
au japon pour réaliser des maquis aux
fruits ou apprendre à concevoir une
petite table en bois
camille lambert qui vous proposera
demain à vendredi encore plus d'idées de
sorties et d'activités à faire sur le
territoire dans son set 8 loisirs c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve dès lundi pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]